ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
HURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER FOR THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW MOAN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THE OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SAID OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF THE MISTER SPEAKER.
WE OFFER ST PATRICK'S PRAYER AS
WE RECOGNIZE THE GIVES ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
HAVE BROUGHT THIS COUNTRY AND
TODAY ESPECIALLY IRISH
IMMIGRANTS AND ONCE AGAIN.
WE RENEW OUR CALL FOR FREE AND
UNITED IRELAND.
LET US PRAY.
MAY THE STRENGTH OF GOD PILOT US.
MAY THE POWER OF GOD PRESERVE US.
MAY THE WISDOM OF GOD INSTRUCT
US.
MAY THE HAND OF GOD PROTECT US.
MAY THE WAY OF GOD DIRECTORS.
MAY THE SHIELD OF GOD DEFEND US.
MAY THE HOST OF GOD GUARD US
AGAINST THE SNARES OF THE EVIL
ONES.
AGAINST TEMPTATIONS OF THE WORLD.
MAY THE LORD BE WITH US.
MAY THE LORD BE BEFORE US.
MAY THE LORD BE AN S..
LORD THE OVER ALL.
MADE AYE SALVATION LORD ALWAYS
BE OURS THIS DAY --
LORD AND EVER MORE [inaudible]
A MAN.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GALLAGHER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING THE
FLAG OF OUR GREAT COUNTRY
[inaudible]
SALUTE.
PLEDGE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINETEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE AM ON ALL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHEAPER KEY DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING KIRK CLAFLIN AND LOUIS
READING THE ROLL WAS CALLED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIN TRYING TO
FORM CALL THE ASSEMBLY.
PUSHED HER BONTA MOVES AND
MISTER BREAUX SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM GRAYSON.
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KADI
PETRIE-NORRIS IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARIE WALDRON.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CALDERON.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER BONTA HE ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MULLIN AND WEBER. TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLINS GUESTS WILL BE IN THE
AREA OF THE MEMBERS DESKS FOR
THE IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE
CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I FOR THE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CARDIO AND
SANTIAGO TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AND PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER A. B. SIXTY
FRIEDMAN FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
YOU HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST IN THE
CHAMBER MEMBERS MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
DOCTOR CHEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ALL CONTRIBUTE
TO CAMERON KNOWN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MISS CALIFORNIA
OUTSTANDING TEEN.
CAMERON DONE WAS CROWNED MISS
CALIFORNIA'S OUTSTANDING TEAM ON
JUNE TWENTY NINTH. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND COMPLETED TWO WEEKS
LATER IN ORLANDO AT THE MISS
AMERICA'S OUTSTANDING TEEN
COMPETITION MY FRIENDS WERE
LOOKING AT A FUTURE MISS AMERICA.
OUT OF FIFTY ONE STATE
REPRESENTATIVES KAREN PLACE IN
TOP NINE FINALISTS AND ONE A
PRELIMINARY AWARD FOR EVENING
WEAR AN ONSTAGE QUESTIONS.
CAMERON ADICIONAL TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND AND SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
MISS AMERICA'S OUTSTANDING TEEN
ORGANIZATION AND A HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SCHOLARSHIPS
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF ALL ALABAMA.
THANKS THE MISS AMERICA
ORGANIZATION CAMERA WILL SEE THE
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
AND BE DEBT FREE UPON
GRADUATIONS AND CAMERAS PERSONAL
MESSAGE AND MISSION FOR YEARS
SHE HAS SPOKEN THOUSAND YOUTH IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS PROMOTING HER
ANTI PULLING PLATFORM.
TEACH THEM TO BE UP STANDARDS
VERSES BYSTANDERS.
PLEASE MEMBERS JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING CAMERA DON'T MISS
CALIFORNIA OUTSTANDING TEAM
.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I'M DELIGHTED
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY AND
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT WERE
VISITING WITH US TODAY.
THE DISTRICT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
TRANSIT AND FERRY SERVICES IN
THE GOLDEN GATE QUARTER.
AS WELL AS OPERATING AND
MAINTAINING THE BEAUTIFUL GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE ITSELF WE HAVE WITH
US TODAY AND THE SOUTH SIDE OF
THE GALLERY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS SABRINA HERNANDEZ THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE DISTRICT
DENNIS SMALL AGAIN A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD GERALD COCHRAN AND THE
SECRETARY OF THE DISTRICT.
EMMERICH CO ONE PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THEM TO OUR SIMPLY
TODAY
.
A. N. MR GABRIEL.
YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MODESTO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO INTRODUCE A
NUMBER OF STUDENT ELECTED
OFFICIALS FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE WHO ARE
HERE --
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF FIXING
OUR BROKEN FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THESE WONDERFUL
STUDENTS
.
AND MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU WERE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS FROM CAL POLY
UNIVERSITY TODAY.
WE HAVE TWENTY STUDENTS FROM CAL
POLY IS COLLEGE OF AGRICULTURE
AND THEY'RE HERE TO PRESENT ON
ISSUES FACING THE AG INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
GO MUSTANGS AND GIVE A WARM
WELCOME THANKS
.
AND DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MEMBERS
AND MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT TO YOU. TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
TREMENDOUS SIGNIFICANCE IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST ONE IS JOINING ME HERE
ON THE FLOOR.
AND THEY ALSO IN THE GALLERY.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
AND WELCOME THE MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK WOMEN INCORPORATED.
THE SAN DIEGO CHAPTER HERE IN
THE CALPERS WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
THE MISSION OF THE NATIONAL
COALITION OF ONE HUNDRED BLACK
WOMEN IS TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF BLACK WOMEN AND GIRLS TO
REMOTE LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
GENDER EQUITY IN THE AREAS OF
HEALTH.
EDUCATION AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT.
THERE ARE SIX CHAPTERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN I LOS ANGELES
ONE IN OAKLAND WHEN AN ORANGE
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO AND SILICON
VALLEY.
TODAY THE NATIONAL MOVEMENT HAS
GARNERED THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
OVER THE YEARS THROUGHOUT SIX
SIXTY CHAPTERS REPRESENTING
TWENTY EIGHT STATES.
WE HAVE HERE WITH US ON THE
FLOOR TODAY DOCTOR ELIZABETH
CHERYL DAVIS WAS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER. SEVEN
FRAZIER WHOSE IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER.
DOCTOR COULD NET PARKER WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE LOS ANGELES
CHAPTER CHAU PERRY LEAGUE WHOSE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF
OAKLAND CHAPTER OF GENESIS
CHAFING WHO'S THE PRESIDENT OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY CHAPTER.
KAREN GILBERT PRESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO CHAPTER MAXINE HICKMAN
WHOSE IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER AND
EILEEN CASA NOT OF A WHICH IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SILICON
VALLEY CHAPTER.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE JOINED BY
FORTY MEMBERS OF THAT ARE HERE
IN THE GALLERY THAT ARE PART OF
THE COALITION.
SO LET US GIVE --
A GROUND OF APPLAUSE TO THE
CLOSEST
[inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED MEMBERS.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A SPECIAL DAY
TO HAVE THIS MANY AFRICAN
AMERICAN DIGNITARIES IN THE
HOUSE.
NOT JUST THE MEMBERS BUT THOSE
WERE LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
I AM HONORED TODAY TO PRESENT TO
YOU AN ORGANIZATION.
WHEN YOU SO SAGE THE BLACK
LAWYERS CALIFORNIA HERE TO THE
ASSEMBLY?
THE BLACK LAWYERS HAVE A AND I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THIS
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE IT HAVE
SIGNIFICANCE TO ME.
THIS ORGANIZATION WAS FOUNDED
ALL FORTY YEARS AGO. EIGHT AND
SUSIE ESTATE BRILLIANT AND
DEDICATED LAWYERS --
FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT.
THAT WE HAVE A VOICE.
IN WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS A RESULT OF THEIR
LEADERSHIP.
WE HAVE HAD TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF BLACK JUDGES.
WE'VE HAD AN ADVOCACY GROUP TO
RIDE A MIX.
OF BREEZE ON OUR BEHALF ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
CALIFORNIA'S LINE.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT I
PERSONALLY HAVE SPENT A LOT OF
THEIR PERSONAL TIME AND EFFORTS
OF ENERGY.
IN THE EARLY DAYS.
MY HUSBAND WAS ONE OF THE EIGHT
FOUNDER OF THE TABLE I KNOW THE
WORK THEY PUT INTO IT.
I KNOW THE INVESTMENT THEY'VE
MADE IN THEIR OWN PERSONAL
RESOURCES TO GET THIS
ORGANIZATION ESTABLISHED.
AND TO GIVE SOMETHING TO
CALIFORNIA THAT IT DID NOT HAVE.
WHICH IS A VOICE OF BRILLIANT
BLACK LITIGATORS WHO HAD
ACTUALLY ADVOCATE ON OUR BEHALF
EVERY LEVEL.
THEY NOW REPRESENT OVER SIX
THOUSAND LAWYERS AND JUDGES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE A VOICE ON THE BAR OF
THE NATIONAL BAR ASSOCIATION AND
THEY BASICALLY MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THEM TODAY IS NOT ONLY THE
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BAR DAMON WOULD BROWN. ONE OF
THE PAST THE PRESIDENT ELECT AND
HOUSTON.
EILEEN TALKS ABOUT WHO WAS ONE
OF THE VICE PRESIDENTS OF THE
NORTH.
I'M LINDA MURRAY WAS A VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE SOUTH.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF LOCAL
CHAPTERS THAT ARE REPRESENTED
BUT IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE
TO PRESENT TO YOU.
A POWER HOUSE ORGANIZATION THE
OFTEN CALL CABLE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK LAWYERS
THANK YOU
.
AND MISTER NAZARIAN YOU HAVE
GUESTS WITH US TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I AM VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT. TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR SIX
EXTRAORDINARY YOUNG WOMEN FROM
OAKWOOD HIGH SCHOOL IN NORTH
HOLLYWOOD IN MY DISTRICT.
TOGETHER THEY WORKED AFTER
SCHOOL HOURS TO FUNDRAISE AND
PRODUCE A FILM THAT JUST WON THE
OSCAR FOR BEST DOCUMENTARY SHORT.
THE DOCUMENTARY CALLED PERIOD.
END OF SENTENCE.
IS ABOUT WOMEN IN RURAL INDIA
THE TABOO AROUND MENSTRUATION IN
THEIR CULTURE AND THE BARRIERS
IT CREATES FOR THEM.
THEY ARE ALL PART OF THE SCHOOL
CLUB CALLED THE PAD PROJECT.
THE CLUB TURNED INTO A NONPROFIT
AND STARTED FUNDRAISING THROUGH
CROWDFUNDING BAKE SALES AND YOGA
CLASSES TO RAISE MONEY FOR A
MACHINE.
THAT MAKES BIODEGRADABLE
SANITARY PADS FOR RULE INDIAN
VILLAGES BY THE WAY IF ANY OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH --
FINANCING FILMS --
IN HOLLYWOOD --
BAKE SALES ARE NOT ONE WAY OF
DOING IT.
SO TRIBUTE TO THEIR HARD WORK.
AS THE FILM EXPLAINS MANY WOMEN
IN GLOBAL RURAL COMMUNITIES STOP
GOING TO SCHOOL WHEN THEY LACK
ACCESS TO CLEAN HYGIENE PRODUCTS
THE FILM DOCUMENTS THE WORK THAT
THE PAP PROJECT IS DOING.
IN INDIA TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
CLEAN FEMALE HYGIENE PRODUCTS
AND THE GATE THE NEED FOR YOUNG
WOMEN TO QUIT SCHOOL THE PATH
PROJECT.
HAS BROUGHT TO MORE PAD MACHINES
TO A SINCE THE FILM WAS RELEASED
LAST YEAR AND PLANS TO CONTINUE
THEIR WORK INTERNATIONALLY.
PLEASE WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR MASON MAGGIE.
NAOMI MEYER DOROTHEA.
LIE I AND MY LOVE FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK AND THE
INCREDIBLE WORK OF MELISSA
BURTON --
THE PRODUCER OF THE DOCUMENTARY
AN ENGLISH TEACHER AT OAKWOOD
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE [inaudible]
UHHUH.
IT IS CRISTINA GARCIA ON THIS
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I WANTED TO
ADD A LITTLE BIT TO THE COMMENTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE --
DOES MENTION THE PAP PROJECT WAS
YOUNG LADIES ARE NOT IS WORKING
ON MAKING SURE THERE'S AWARENESS
AROUND MITCHELL EQUITY IN INDIA
BUT MITCHELL EQUITY IN GENERAL
OUT THERE.
INTO THE WORK I IS NOT SPECIFIC
TO AN AREA WE HAVE THE SAME
ISSUES HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH IT'S A TO
WHILE THE STATE.
I'M SO THEY CONTINUE --
TO SHED LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE BUT
ALSO SAID LIKE THAT IT'S OUR
BIOLOGY THAT THERE'S NOTHING TO
BE ASHAMED OF THE WORKING TO
BRING NOW THAT STIGMA.
EXCITING FOR ME THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE TO SEE
THESE YOUNG FOLKS WITH THE
CHARGE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY IT'S VERY
IT'S AND MOVIES.
I WHICH IS NEVER TALKED ABOUT AT
ANY POINT AND SO THEY ALSO MAKE
USE THAT THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE ACADEMY OUT
THERE.
SO I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO BE THE CHANGE
AGENT THAT WE WANT TO BE
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR ACADEMY
AWARD WIN.
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
LIVING TURN NEXT INTRODUCTION
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND UP.
MEMBERS IT'S ON MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU --
IN THE GALLERY.
OTHER STUDENTS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AND SOME OF THE TEACHERS.
OF THE ROCK HOME SCHOOL IN THE
FRESNO AND CLOVIS AREA THEY ARE
HERE TOURING THE CAPITAL.
AND TAKING A A GOOD LOOK AT HOW
WE CONDUCT A THEIR BUSINESS
WOULD YOU PLEASE WELCOME NOT THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
FACULTY FROM THE ROCK.
HOME SCHOOL THANK.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON.
MISS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER NAZARIAN FIRST YES MISTER
NAZARIAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SECOND GUESSED INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES OF WEEK WE WE THROW
AROUND THE PHRASE HERE --
ON OUR FLOOR ABOUT A BILL BEING
VERY STRAIGHT FORWARD --
AND WE HEAR THAT ESPECIALLY IN
JUNE AND AUGUST QUITE A BIT --
WELL.
LAST TERM I DID HAVE A BILL THAT
WAS PRETTY STRAIGHT FORWARD AB.
SIX ONE THREE AND IT TOOK TWO
YEARS FOR IT TO FINALLY MAKE ITS
WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
GET SIGNED.
AND SO.
THAT WAS A BILL THAT WAS GOING
TO HELP PROMOTE.
BY THE USE OF A REFRACTIVE
REFRACT OF MORE JOBS BEING
BURGEONING AN OPENING UP THROUGH
THE RIFFLES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- IT'S
IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE --
TO RECOGNIZE DOCTOR MARYLAND
ROSSO BRAY WHO IS HERE ON BEHALF
OF RIFFLES.
OF LEGISLATION THAT HAS ALREADY
HELPED PROMOTE THE OPENING OF
ADDITIONAL CENTERS IN THE STATE --
AB SIX ONE THREE I WANT TO JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE MISS WENDY CARILLO
AND WELCOMING.
A DOCTOR ROSE SEPARATE FROM
BRUSSELS TO THE CHAMBERS TODAY
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CREO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MEMBERS IT IS MY PLEASURE. TO
WELCOME A SPECIAL VISITOR TO THE
CAPITAL DR MARYLAND ROWS OF RATE
DOCTOR ROSA REYES SERVICE AS THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER AND VICE
PRESIDENT.
OF QUALITY REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
AND LABORATORIES FOR GRATEFUL.
WHICH IS A SPAIN BASED --
BIOMEDICAL COMPANY WITH THEIR
AMERICAN HEADQUARTERS LOCATED IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE IN
THE EL SERENO COMMUNITY WHICH IS
WHERE I LIVE --
GRAVELS PRODUCES PLASMA DERIVED
MEDICINES FOR TREATMENT OF RARE
DISEASES SUCH AS HAVE A PHILLY
AT THAT PLACE CERTAIN WOMEN AT
RISK OF PREMATURE CHILD DELIVERY.
AS SUCH DR ROSA GRAY IT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER NUMBER OF
CENTERS IN OUR WONDERFUL STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE MEMBERS
HELP ME IN WELCOMING DOCTOR
MARYLAND ROSE A GROUP OF RATE TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
WELCOME TO ALL OF OUR GUESTS
TODAY.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF IRISH AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FOR AC ARE THIRTY FOUR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN YOU MAY
OPEN ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A C. R. THIRTY FOUR
DESIGNATES MARCH.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
IN HONOR OF THE MULTITUDE OF
CONTRIBUTIONS AT IRISH AMERICANS
HAVE MADE TO THE COUNTRY AND
STATE.
THIS YEAR OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ALSO MARKS THE ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF IRELAND'S FIRST
OIL.
THE FIRST MEETING OF THE
UNICAMERAL PARLIAMENT OF THE
IRISH REPUBLIC WHICH SERVED AS A
SYMBOL OF RESISTANCE HAS THE
PEOPLE OF IRELAND SOUGHT
INDEPENDENCE.
MILLIONS OF IRISH PEOPLE FACE
WAS SEVERE HARDSHIP DUE TO
FAMINE AND POVERTY IN THEIR
NATION.
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL CENTURIES
IN SEARCH OF A MORE PROMISING
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE JOURNEY TO AMERICA WAS NOT
PAVED WITH GOLD LIKE MANY
IMMIGRANTS THE IRISH SPIRIT OF
DETERMINATION.
PERSEVERANCE AND GRIT PREVAILED
AGAINST CONDITIONS WITH THEIR
HEARTS SET ON THE HORIZON.
IRISH AMERICANS INITIALLY
SUFFERED PREJUDICE AND
DISCRIMINATION UPON FIRST
ARRIVING IN THE UNITED STATES AS
THE YEARS WENT ON IRISH
AMERICANS BECAME DEEPLY
INTEGRATED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
A MADE NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS AT
ALL ASPECTS OF AMERICAN SOCIETY
AND CULTURE.
IRISH AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED
VITAL ROLES IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES NINE IRISH
AMERICAN SIGNED THE DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE AND TWENTY TWO
PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES
HAVE BEEN OF IRISH HERITAGE
INCLUDING.
JOHN F. KENNEDY RONALD REAGAN
BILL CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA.
MANY PEOPLE OF IRISH DESCENT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO GREAT
MOVEMENTS THAT HELPED SHAPE OUR
COUNTRY AND ITS ROLE IN THE
WORLD INCLUDING OF MOTHER JONES
LABOR ACTIVISTS.
LUCY BURNS ACTIVISTS IN THE
WOMEN'S MOVEMENT AND SENATOR
GEORGE MITCHELL NEGOTIATOR OF
THE IRISH PEACE ACCORD.
IRISH AMERICANS OF ALSO PLAYED A
MAJOR ROLE IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS IS GOVERNOR'S
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS CITY MAYORS
AND OTHER PUBLIC OFFICIALS.
WHO HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
BUILD CALIFORNIA INTO THE STATE
THAT IT IS TODAY?
TODAY OVER THIRTY FOUR MILLION
AMERICANS CLAIM IRISH HERITAGE
AND THEY CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA.
ARENAS OF POLITICS ECONOMY AND
CULTURE.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I VOTED THAT THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPENED FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AS WAS MENTIONED THIS IS THE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY VIOLENCE
FIRST PARLIAMENT.
THE MET ON JANUARY TWENTY FIRST.
NINETEEN NINETEEN AND IN DOING
SO CHANGE THE COURSE OF IRISH
HISTORY.
INDEPENDENCE IS ONE SOUGHT TO RE
ESTABLISH JUSTICE TO PROVIDE FOR
THE FUTURE DEFENSE TO ENSURE
PEACE AT HOME.
GOOD WILL WITH ALL NATIONS AND
TO CONSTITUTE A NATIONAL POLICY
BASED UPON PEOPLE'S WILL WITH
EQUAL RIGHTS AND EQUAL TO
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY CITIZEN.
IT ALSO AFFIRMED IRELAND'S
POSITION AS THE GATEWAY TO THE
ATLANTIC THE LAST OUTPOST OF
EUROPE TOWARDS THE WEST.
THE POINT IN WHICH GREAT TRADE
ROUTES BETWEEN EAST AND WEST
CONVERGE.
WE ALSO REMEMBER CONSTANCE MARK
OF IT.
WHO IS THE MINISTER FOR LABOR IN
THE FIRST ALL IN?
NINETEEN NINETEEN SHE WAS THE
FIRST WOMAN ELECTED TO A
NATIONAL PARLIAMENT AND ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS ALSO THE CENTENARY OF
THE FIRST SHOPS OF THE WAR OF
INDEPENDENCE WITH THE AMBUSH IN
COUNTY TIPPERARY ON THE TWENTY
FIRST OF JANUARY.
NINETEEN NINETEEN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS AHEAD WILL COMMEMORATE THE
STRUGGLE THAT HELP IRELAND YOU
ACHIEVE ITS INDEPENDENCE.
THE NEW REPUBLIC WAS MADE
POSSIBLE BY ENORMOUS AMERICA
NINETEEN NINETEEN ALSO WAS THE
CENTENARY OF THE FIRST VISIT OF
THE HARSH HEAD OF STATE.
TABLE ERA PRESIDENT OF THE IRISH
REPUBLIC STARTED HIS VISIT IN
SAN FRANCISCO IN JULY NINETEEN
NINETEEN HE WOULD ALSO VISIT LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO ON THAT
TRIP.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
THE COUNTRY OF IRELAND ON THEIR
CENTENNIAL AND INDEPENDENCE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
THIRTY FOURS AS A PROUD IRISH
AMERICAN.
AND I I I THINK A LOT OF OF MY
OWN FAMILIES --
HISTORY OF COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY.
MY ANCESTORS ARRIVED IN NEW YORK
IN --
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT MY GREAT
GREAT GRANDFATHER ANTHONY
GALLAGHER WAS BORN IN NEW YORK.
SHORTLY AFTER THEY ARRIVED AND
EVENTUALLY IMMIGRATED OUT TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS WAS A LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY FAMILY
ACTUALLY MET.
ANOTHER IRISH IMMIGRANT FAMILY
THAT -- HAD
SETTLED AND NICHOLAS CALIFORNIA --
THAT HAD ACTUALLY SEVERAL
DAUGHTERS AND MY ANCESTOR
MARRIED.
ALLEN -- AND
THEY HAD SEVEN KIDS AND SO THAT
YOU KNOW THEY'VE THEY MADE THIS
THEIR HOME --
THEY SETTLED US ON A A PLOT OF
LAND -- THAT
MY FAMILY STILL FORMS --
TO THIS DAY.
AND YOU KNOW BEING ABLE.
TO HOMELAND AND BE ABLE TO FARM
AND BE FREE FROM.
THE CONFINES OF A TYRANNICAL
GOVERNMENT.
PROVED TO BE A GAME CHANGER FOR
SO MANY --
AND CERTAINLY IT WAS FOR MY
FAMILY.
AS NOW I'M THE SIXTH GENERATION --
NOW LIVING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WORKING HERE RAISING THE NEXT
GENERATION I AS YOU KNOW I HAVE
FIVE CHILDREN SO HAVEN'T QUITE.
REACHED MY GREAT GREAT
GRANDFATHER'S --
LEVEL YET NONE THE LESS --
IT'S A STORY NOT JUST OF OF
IRISH IMMIGRANTS BUT OF ALL THE
IMMIGRANTS.
WHO HAVE MADE THIS NATION GREAT?
AND THAT.
EACH SUCCESSIVE --
GROUP OF IMMIGRANTS WHO COMES
THIS COUNTRY HELPS CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE VIBRANCY OF THIS GREAT
NATION THE GREATNESS OF THIS
NATION --
AND I THINK YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
REASONS WE CELEBRATE TODAY IS
BECAUSE WE ON OUR PART.
THROUGH THROUGH PUBLIC SERVICE --
THROUGH FIGHTING --
FOR GREATER EXPANSIONS OF
EQUALITY.
IN OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND OF ENSURING THAT ALL HAVE AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
HAPPINESS. TO TO TO EXPAND THAT
AMERICAN DREAM.
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
VERY IRISH IN VERY IMMIGRANT --
IN NATURE AND SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE.
JOIN US IN.
IN SUPPORTING ACR THIRTY FOUR
AND THAT GREAT IMMIGRANT STORY
THAT WE ARE ALL A PART OF THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU MAY CLOSE.
LET ME JUST.
SIMPLY THANK MY IRISH CAUCUS
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR GOOD WORDS
AN ASSET FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE WE WILL MOVE MOVE
TO A VOTE ON THE MEASURE.
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SPECIAL
KNOWLEDGE MEN OF OUR GUESTS MR
MILLING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
JUST WHILE WELCOMING MY FAMILY
TO THE GREEN CARPET.
MY WIFE JESSICA STAM FELL MULLIN
AND OUR TWIN BOYS LIAM AND
LANDON WHO ARE FOURTEEN MONTHS
OLD AND NOT FULLY WALKING YET.
HEAVEN HELP US WHEN THEY DO.
MR BRO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE A
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MR ROBERT --
DRISKELL WAS APPOINTED IRELAND'S
GENERAL COUNSEL TO THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE SERVED
OVERSEAS AS COUNSEL.
AND IRELAND'S EMBASSY IN THE
KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA DEPUTY
HEAD OF MISSION AND IRELAND'S
EMBASSY OF THE UNITED ARAB
EMIRATES AND IN IRELAND'S PART
PERMANENT MISSION TO THE
EUROPEAN UNION IN BRUSSELS.
IN IRELAND HE SERVED AS PRIVATE
SECRETARY.
TO AND ALSO TO IRELAND'S
MINISTER OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS
BEFORE TAKING UP HIS CURRENT
POSITION ROBERT WAS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE TRADE DIVISION
THE IRISH DEPARTMENT OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY LET'S
CONGRATULATE HIM.
AND HIS LOVELY WIFE THEY JUST
WELCOMED THEIR FIRST CHILD.
AT THE BEGINNING OF MARCH.
MR JUST BECAUSE JOINED TODAY BY
MS SO SALIM KELLY PRESENTLY
IRISH IMMIGRATION PASTORAL
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND FATHER BRENDAN BIG BROAD
PLEASE GIV THEM A WARM WELCOME
.
MEMBERS YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TRADITIONAL IRISH DANCING IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE IRISH
CULTURE DATING BACK TO FIVE
HUNDRED BC.
THE CANNELLA SCHOOL OF IRISH
DANCE HOLDS MANY TITLES AND IS
PERFORMING LOCALLY FOR TWO
DECADES THEY PERFORMED HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY ON MANY OF OUR
CELEBRATIONS IN THE PAST.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LET'S
WELCOME THE CANAL THE SCHOOL OF
IRISH DANCE [inaudible]
ALL
.
THAT WAS INCREDIBLE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING MUSIC AND DANCE ARE
CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU TO THE KENNELLY SCHOOL
OF IRISH DANCE FOR VISITING US
TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AS A SOUVENIR OF OUR OBSERVANCE
OF IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
THE MENTORS HAVE BEEN DELIVERED
TO YOUR OFFICES AND PLACED ON
YOUR DESK.
THE SHAMROCK PLANS REPRESENTS
THE NUMBER.
THREE EVERYTHING GOOD IN IRELAND
COMES IN THREES AND THE GOURMET
JELLY BEANS ON YOUR DESK.
ARE FROM THE COMPANY IN MISTER
MULLIN HOMETOWN OF SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO.
ON BEHALF OF MR MULLIN MR BROWN
MR O'DONNELL AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF IRISH HERITAGE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE DANCERS
AND THE IRISH DELEGATION FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY.
NOW MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY SECOND READING
A FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN
WITH THE MOMENT.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED IN.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AND THREE IN THE
ABSENCE OF AN OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AND
GIVE YOUR SPECULATIVE CHIN TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS.
TODAY I HAVE THE IMMENSE
PRIVILEGE OF ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY.
OF ROTH OF ALL HIGH SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL MR HENRY RODEO.
WHO PASSED ON JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH?
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF EIGHTY TWO
THIS IS A VERY SPECIAL A GERMAN
IN MEMORY FOR ME BECAUSE MISS
FROM KEEL PLAY SUCH AN IMPORTANT
AND PIVOTAL ROLE.
IN MY YOUNG LIFE.
THE FIRST ELECTION I EVER ONE
ACTUALLY WAS THAT OF SOPHOMORE
CLASS PRESIDENT.
MY FIRST ENDORSEMENT ROLLOUT WAS
THAT OF MR TRUMP HE'LL.
I DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME THAT
HE HAD ALSO ENDORSED MY OPPONENT.
THAT'S OKAY.
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED.
IN ALL OF US.
I WON THAT ELECTION.
AND I'M WEARING MY LEADERSHIP
SWEATER.
EVERY TIME I WOULD WEAR IT.
AND WHILE I WALKED THE HALLS AT
ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL IN OUR
BUILDING OR THE A BUILDING.
HE POINTS TO THE ARE
[inaudible]
ARE HERE.
AND SAY SOMETHING LIKE.
LOOKING GOOD WENDY.
OR LOOKING GOOD MISCARRY.
MR NACCHIO AS ALWAYS WEARING
SOMETHING THAT SHOWED ROOSEVELT
PRIDE.
HIS WHITE POLOS WITH A BRIGHT.
RED ARE OR A TEDDY BEAR.
OR RED POLO WITH THE YELLOW ARE
IN THE TEDDY BEAR.
HE SHOWED US ALL WHAT IT MEANT
TO HAVE PRIDE IN OUR SCHOOL.
WHETHER YOU WERE BEING BUSSED IN
FROM SOUTH CENTRAL TO ATTEND
RULES ABOUT MAGNET.
OR IF YOU WERE A KID FROM THE
NEIGHBORHOOD JUST LIKE I WAS.
HE LED BY EXAMPLE AND WHAT IT
MEANT TO HAVE PRIDE.
IN OURSELVES AND WHERE WE CAME
FROM.
IT WAS AROUND JUNIOR YEAR WHERE
I STARTED ACTING UP AND GOT
KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL FOR SOME
SHENANIGANS.
AS AN ELEVENTH GRADER.
MR TRUMP KEEL PERSONALLY CALLED
MY PARENTS.
NOT A FUN CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
AND HE ENROLLED ME BACK IN
SCHOOL.
TWICE.
HE MADE SURE.
THAT I GRADUATED HE CALLED ME
INTO HIS OFFICE.
AND HE TOLD ME THAT I HAD
POTENTIAL.
THAT I COULD AND THAT I SHOULD.
GRADUATE.
HE MADE SURE THAT I ENROLLED IN
ADULT SCHOOL.
AND CATCH UP ON MY CREDITS.
AND I DID.
AND WHEN I WALKED ACROSS THE
STAGE AT THE SHRINE AUDITORIUM.
WITH MY CLASS AND ON TIME HE
GAVE ME THE BIGGEST HUG.
IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPACTFUL LIFE
CHANGING MOMENTS OF MY YOUNG.
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD LIFE.
I AM GRATEFUL THE MISTER FROM
KEEL TOOK THE TIME.
HE TOOK THE TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT I WASN'T.
ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THAT I WASN'T ANOTHER GIRL FROM
BOYLE HEIGHTS OR EAST LA
FORMALLY UNDOCUMENTED ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER.
FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN.
WHO DROPPED OUT?
TO ME AND TO MY FOUR YOUNGER
SISTERS BECAUSE HE ALWAYS SAID
THAT I NEEDED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
THESE ARE.
MY STORY IS IS NOT UNIQUE THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF STORIES LIKE
MINE FROM FELLOW ROUGHRIDERS.
HE WAS A UNIQUE AND SPECIAL MAN
WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT HIS SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND OUR EDUCATION.
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY HE IMPACTED
GENERATIONS OF FAMILY.
MR GILL WAS BORN IN EL PASO.
BUT RAISED IN BOYLE HEIGHTS HE
GRADUATED FROM ROOSEVELT HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
AND WENT ON TO EAST LA COLLEGE.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF OREGON ON
A BASKETBALL SCHOLARSHIP.
HE HAD A CAREER AS AN EDUCATOR
AND ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
[inaudible]
INFO IMPACTING.
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES. ONE OF HIS PROUDEST
ACHIEVEMENT.
WAS HIRING OVER NINETY ROLES OF
OUR ALUMNI TO RETURN.
IN SERVICE TEACHERS AT OUR
SCHOOL.
AFTER RETIREMENT IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE HIT HE COOKED
AND SERVED FOOD FOR HOMELESS FOR
THE HOMELESS TWICE A WEEK.
HE VOLUNTEERED AS AN USHER.
AT THE WITH YOUR AREA COMMUNITY
CHURCH.
HE ATTENDED BIBLE STUDY.
HE SERVED ON NUMEROUS
SCHOLARSHIPS AND ALUMNI BOARDS
ANY SPEND TIME WITH HIS FAMILY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS MARGARET
BY HIS WIFE MARGARET WHOM HE WAS
MARRIED TO FOR ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS.
HIS TWO DAUGHTERS AND LISA AND
CASSANDRA.
GRANDDAUGHTERS NO VAN SEWING HIS
SON GABRIEL DAUGHTER AND ALL
THAT THE GRANDDAUGHTER GLORIA
SISTER EMMA.
AND MANY NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO
AS RULES ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL IS IN
THE FIFTY THIRD DISTRICT.
AND WE HAVE MEMBERS AND YOUNG
STUDENTS OF OUR COMMUNITIES OF
WHETHER THE FIFTY FIRST OR THE
FIFTY THIRD.
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
MISTRAL KEOGH SELECT A THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALDERON FOR
SHARING THIS SPECIAL ADJOURNMENT
IN MEMORY.
WITH US BECAUSE MISTRAL KEEL
LIVED IN THE FIFTY SEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
LIKE MANY EDUCATORS THAT WE HAVE
ALL BEEN BACK BEEN IMPACTED BY
MISTER JOHN KEEL HAS IMPACTED.
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS
BOYLE HEIGHTS.
AND ACROSS MANY MANY FAMILIES.
MAY HE REST IN POWER.
AND MAY HIS GUIDANCE.
SERVE OTHER FELLOW ROUGHRIDERS
FOR MANY YEARS TO COME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR SHARING THAT WITH US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU HOUSE LIKE TO CHIME IN
ON MISTER ON QUEUE FOR ALL THE
OTHER STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE TODAY --
IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT
YOU MEET A PRINCIPAL WHO
DEDICATE THEIR ENTIRE LIFE. TO
HELPING PEOPLE WHETHER THEY WERE%
A PRINCIPAL AT THE TIME OR
RETIRED AT THE TIME WE HEAR THE
STORIES OVER AND OVER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ABOUT MISTER ON HERE WHO HELPED
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WE HAVE ONE EXAMPLE OUR
COLLEAGUE WHO WAS HELPED.
BUT ALL ACROSS OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WE FIND STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED BY THIS INDIVIDUAL
CERTAINLY AN OUTSTANDING
ROUGHRIDERS WE WOULD CALL IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WILL NEVER FORGET HIM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES TO THE DEATH TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME SENATOR
HILLS ARE FLOOR.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
AB MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THERE WILL BE A RECEPTION IN
HONOR OF IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH IN MISTER MULLINS OFFICE
ROOM THREE ONE SIX ZERO UPON A
GERMAN OBSESSION.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH TWELFTH WE
HAVE A CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY MARCH THIRTEENTH CHECK
INS THEY MARCH FOURTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED IN RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES SAN MISTER FLORES
SECONDS THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH
FOURTEENTH AT NINE AM.
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED